so once again the end of the year is
upon us and this time we can finally
reflect back and all the anime we got to
see but before that's how about we look
at all the great things that happen in
the past year remember back in the day
when memes are just stupid macro images
about cats they were passed around the
office to be laughed at well helped very
simple days are unfortunately long over
as 2016 marks the year that real life
became a meme and the whole world was
laughing at itself Britain starts things
off to the mid-season twist by actually
ragequitting out of Europe because I got
tired of picking up all the tabs at the
EU pub giving solace to millions of
Brits as they finally had a topic to
talk to each other about other than the
weather but of course those
attention-seeking Americans not wanting
to be outdone by anyone hosted the
biggest prank gone wrong of all time by
electing The Annoying Orange as
president leaving Hillary supporters
completely dumbfounded regretting that
she probably just didn't dab hard enough
to achieve victory it was a year of a
shock with no exception to those we lost
we unfortunately had to say goodbye to
such influential figures as David Bowie
Prince Alan Rickman Muhammad Ali
recently-announced Carrie Fisher and
people using the word literally and
cringe the way they were actually
intended so should come as no surprise
that the biggest and most mourned / loss
felt by anyone throughout the world was
for that of a [ __ ] gorilla but hey
enough of real world events we're here
to talk about anime and all the weird
and wonderful moments that mattered to
us of course I can't cover everything
but this is everything that stood out to
me and will that Wheatley whine back to
January and the start of the year as we
start things off with the hottest new
show of the winter season
following second this is in right show
that's doing all right Dave hey Dave
we got the wrong opening for the show or
something yes the goes to anime that
started everyone off this year was of
course a race which had a stranglehold
on the entire community for a brief
period this murder mystery thriller
follows a story of a dude who has the
innate ability of being sent back in
time before major accidents occur in
order to prevent them after being
wrongfully accused of murdering his mum
he sent back to his childhood Way tries
to prevent a series of child murders and
find out who the real culprit was all
those years ago in Netflix's making a
murderer but with time-travel [ __ ]
scars it's anime this genuinely
interesting concept have the community
grips every week waiting for new
developments even if there are some
small things off of the writings several
of the kids acted and talks like mature
adults instead of being like you know
annoying spots kids leading to some
genuinely awkward moments of a mentally
29 year old guy having romantic tensions
with an 11 year old kid it's probably
not pedophilia cos is cute right but it
could sometimes be overlooked when you
remember the dark themes of the show and
the events that the kids had to endure
however the show lost massive steam with
a culpa reveal ended up being more
predictable than an average [ __ ]
episode of scooby-doo which led to a
rather weak and cheesy ending compared
to the great build-up we were riding on
for the majority of the series or so I
don't know why I'm the only one who
apparently has a problem with this
opening for sounding more like a bloody
in the root opening than one for a
time-travel murder mystery thriller yes
I know it's by asian kung-fu generation
but come on this opening sounds nothing
like the general tone of the series
elsewhere in the season the GAO chica
she gave us a resident best girl debate
in a show about candy yep candy I mean
who doesn't love watching shows about
the sweet sweet taste of candy rock hard
candy soft candy and who can forget
delicious cream pies this image what a
nice warm cream pie what date continued
for a second please they show the
absolute might of the Japanese military
valiantly cowering and nothing striking
terror to the hearts of some medieval
armed with pitchforks because of this it
was discussed as being possible
propaganda with the Japanese government
and SDF being painted in an
overwhelmingly positive light while
other countries having an almost
cartoonish level of villainy such as the
way they presented the American
president as an egotist called
power-hungry blond guy with no regard to
public opinion a wait a minute power
cord free running finally got some anime
and print subscribe alternates which
sounded like a really cool animated
concept if you base it on all the sick
videos found on YouTube but the anime
itself basically boils down to a bunch
of dudes running around trying to find
the most convoluted way possible to
high-five each other at top speeds
dimension W gave the biggest plot twist
in anime history by having a girl walked
in on while taking a piss without losing
her [ __ ] mind in a pretty average
semi episodic sci-fi show that didn't
really do much to stand out except
having the protagonists who are very out
of character dogs in the opening as if
this anime was actually about someone
auditioning for some stick dance crew or
something
[Music]
rimu Garvin fancy an ass gave us a
totally original premise by throwing an
unwitting group of individuals until
fantasy world the catch this times that
it's grounded in reality and everyone is
weak as [ __ ] heavy emphasis was put on
the most insignificant of battles I was
a valiant attempt at creating a more
serious addition to the concept this
year's latest attempt show us that not
all CG animes bad came from polygons
pictures Arjun a show that got largely
overlooked because any anime CG equals
bad anime CG which is a shame because
once you look past the visuals this is
one of the most compelling slickly
written thrillers to come out in recent
years complete with abilities basically
psycho passes makishima if you were a
standard kyoto animation stepped out
that comfort zone with myriad colors
phantom world showing us that when there
are not dangling yuri bait in front of
us or Murray pandering they are not
above good old-fashioned tasteless
fanservice featuring more accidental
trips in town tease a girl who can
firmly deep throat a Titan and of course
a classic anime boob physics rave party
those are sleeper hits this season
definitely belong to Connor Suba a show
about a guy who is transported to our oh
god dammit but actually surprised the
cleans you by being a genuinely funny
and charming take on the genre there was
several things the show just did right
by the one who stole with the show Anna
Haas was of course miss galaxy note
seven the adorable made sure refused to
learn anything but explosion magic
bringing new meaning to the phrase who
here wants to blow me sure
a spring rolled around everyone was just
getting over their disappointment of the
erased ending we all had enough of
stupid time-travel gimmicks to draw us
in and we were looking for something new
to latch on to or at least
yes this year an anime undoubtedly
belong to r e0 the timely preacher took
over the community essentially just
thousands of people watching the longest
most emotionally draining let's play of
Dark Souls in anime form as viewers
tuned in weekly to watch some poor sod
get tortured physically and mentally
creating the entirely new genre suffer
porn but out of all the moments the most
talked-about part had nothing to do of
suffering what was of course the I love
Emilia moments triggering unprecedented
scenes of an entire community declaring
a character undeniably worst girl for
doing absolutely [ __ ] nothing
yes REM lashes in the biggest wave of
salt this community has seen since the
dark or emo Wars of 2013 in response to
scenes of what is commonly known as a
massive dick move but I've already
covered re0
extensively in my review and parody of
it so instead of repeating myself let me
take this time to talk about my actual
favorite show of the season and a time
when the only way shown in battle series
would get noticed would be by adding a
darker twist to it or subverting the
tropes in the clever way or by being
JoJo's it was nice to see a shounen that
just went back to its roots and doing
its really [ __ ] well boku no hero
academia was nothing more than a
celebration of the tropes you've seen
many times before but refined to a tee
demonstrated to us so you don't always
need to do something over the original
or off-the-cuff if you just get the
basics absolutely right there keep your
childlike desire to become a hero make
him incredibly sympathetic to any person
who's cheered for the heroes as a kid
and all might with one of the most
likeable characters I've seen in anime
humanizing the charismatic mentor type
in a way that you looked up to him yeah
it's related to him at the same time the
charm of the series made it incredibly
easy to get behind the characters and
moments no matter how cheesy or
predictable they were giving you back
your giddy childhood excitements at the
best of times so I highly recommend it
for any shown in fans or if you're just
looking for something fun also not to
mention next season we're guessing at
Warner and Ark tornament Ark
else when spring cabin era the iron
fortress gave us the back muscles we
never knew we have the bone in a four in
hey wet I thought this was meant to be
attack on Titan season two yeah
studio trigger gave us a show but a
group of quirky individuals becoming
friends and developing feelings for each
other
written by Mario Curtis so you know that
means
yes this of course meant yet another
group of friends falling for each other
without getting their feelings returned
when looking past that it asks a
question what would happen if humans
could totally empathize with one another
in a way that I can't see being explored
anywhere but in anime it even had a
character which was Marco from Keola
killed I'm right and I also need to
mention this great original opening that
looks so trippy and cool emotion wonder
what kind of a genius person could come
up with imagery like this
[Music]
a whopping 31 characters were introduced
in the first episode of lost village a
show about a group of people running
away from their problems in order to
meet the biggest problem anyone can face
being an awful show it was so awful in
fact there were actually discussions and
whether it was being intentionally bad
my personal take is that it was a
planned love child of Higurashi in Lord
of the Flies but along the way got drunk
tripped over and thought it was meant to
be a sitcom Bukka Wan gave us the cutesy
fanservice show that tried to appeal to
the Motorhead to what saying they didn't
succeed but they just needed to
introduce their characters the correct
way like this some say he's seen every
episode of one piece a hundred times
over and can block a punch from one
punch man all we know is he's called the
Stig
begorrah gave us an annual dose of air
giving us a completely trashy show that
I somehow couldn't find myself hating
imagine a death game starring Lelouch
and his yandere sidekick but every enemy
was a stand user with the most
ridiculous the opie ability you can
think of like a kiosk or immortality or
predicting the future it was like if
mirai nikki a karmic Akio Code Geass and
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure had a drunken
coked up orgy one night and decided to
livestream it you're not proud of the
fact you watched it but it was still
kind of entertaining joke again gave us
a world war two espionage drama which
sounds like a really cool original idea
for anime until you realize how this
would actually work in real life all
right chaps I've just had Intel that one
of us is a spy working with the Japanese
I keep telling you it's not me that's
exactly what a Japanese spy would say
she is a very suspicious I completely
agree with you a random Asian person in
Europe who speaks broken English
Sakamoto desu ka' showed us how to
transcend the limits of cool to a whole
new plane no human has ever reached
before in swag the anime Phoenix rights
gave us a true to the game anime
adaptation that was faithful but
ultimately had little to no reason for
any new comes to choose watching this
over playing the games unless they
didn't own a DS or a pair of hands and
finally this year JoJo's yet again
returned to us in the form of part for
water beautiful do Wang and I mean it's
JoJo's what what can I say about it it's
got this at a point now while I don't
even know if liking JoJo's to death is
something genuine or has become a meme
in and off itself so here you go JoJo's
it's an anime that's good
it's really
good you should watch show joe's Joe
Joseph love Joe Joe's life that's it for
part 1 this year
join me next time when I talk about the
CG that just keeps giving and of course
a bunch of gay people on solid water
[Music]
hey guys gig okay hope you enjoyed the
video thank you very much this month to
Thomas B benson Mooney Moretti I love
Ken and everyone else on patreon for
helping to support me and making this
video possible one spot to is now if you
click on the link here but until then
before to see all the previous anime
year reviews you can also click on the
link now I hope worked my ass off to get
both parts done before year's end so
hopefully they'll come to fruition and
you'll see me again in a few days but
until then I've been gig up and I'll see
you all not in March 2017
probably